the largest single state immigration
rate in US history has divided families
in some Mississippi communities federal
agents yesterday arrested about 680
workers at 7 food processing plants in
six cities the raids apparently planned
for more than a year happened just hours
before President Trump met with victims
of the El Paso shooting Omar Villafranca
is here Omar what do we know about these
raids good morning we know that several
hundred agents surrounded the perimeters
of the food processing centers to
prevent people from leaving and then
after the operation US Attorney Michael
hearse issued a stark warning to
businesses comply with the law or were
coming after you Magdalena Gomez
Gregorio pleaded for the return of her
dad one of hundreds of undocumented
immigrants rounded up Wednesday by
immigration and customs enforcement the
11 year old and other children of those
arrested stayed at a community center
gymnasium overnight after about 600
immigration agents targeted food
processing plants across central
Mississippi some employers were also
arrested while we do welcome folks from
other countries they have to follow our
laws one by one the agents forced
workers to put all their belongings into
plastic bags and then tied their wrists
together with plastic bands the agents
then put them onto buses and brought
them to this Mississippi National Guard
processing center to await their fate
Wednesday's raids marked the largest
workplace raid in one state ever
surpassing a 2008 Mississippi plant
operation where 595 immigrants were
arrested for years and years
Patricia ice is the legal projects
director of the Mississippi immigrant
Rights Alliance what's going to happen
to the migrants now we're hoping that
most of the people will be released and
sent back home some of them may be
fitted with ankle monitors and received
notices to appear at the immigration
in the future these raids are unrelated
to last month's nationwide deportation
operations were only 35 people were
arrested and to follow up on the
business angle ice acting director of
Matthew abalones said employers could
face charges as well if they knowingly
hired workers who were in the country
illegally and that's something a lot of
people are asking about not just the
workers yes what's gonna happen to the
business so the businesses yeah it's
very tough to watch an 11 year old lead
for her father on the on the first day
of school for a lot of these kids yeah
all right thanks worried about those
kids thanks Omar